welcome back to CBS mornings instead of
our usual Talk of the table we're
bringing you a very special conversation
with a surprise Superstar from the Super
Bowl halftime show I know you saw her
deaf performer Look at Her Go Justina
miles went viral for her very high
energy American sign language
interpretation of Rihanna's medley look
at you she also signed lift every voice
and sing before the big game now miles
is the first deaf woman to sign the
Super Bowl halftime show she's a nursing
student at Bowie State University that's
in Maryland and she joins us for her
very first TV interview since the Super
Bowl along with her ASL interpreter
that's Alberto Madero we welcome you all
good morning good to see you Alberto but
I want to talk to you
bravo bravo bravo Justina
you were so fun to watch you were so fun
to watch you just jumped off the screen
and we keep describing you as the first
deaf performer but watching you you
appear to be able to hear the songs can
you tell us your process how were you
able to do what you did
right so yes I communication but it's so
like when you go to an audiologist and
you take a test to go to singing how
like TV that levels to deafness so it's
like
over 30 or 40 they'll consider your
death so either you're like like I can
hear well but I'm still deaf or to
moderately deaf to severely deaf to
profoundly deaf so they have those
levels but they're all still deaf I'm
like considered deaf you're still
considered deaf so watching you was
really I got such a kick out of watching
your expressions and the way that you
signed you were so into what you were
doing how how far in advance did you get
the set list
yes like that goes like into like the
preparation with it and everything so I
got the set list about like five days
before the uh show and I was like
nervous before like getting this I was
like oh my gosh what's she gonna do like
she hasn't been on stage
I'm listening to all your different
songs so I got it I'm like I know all
the songs I was confident I was like yes
so what I did was look over the lyrics
make sure you know I got all the
meanings right but do you memorize the
lyrics yes I remember the lyrics and the
beats that way I can sign the lyrics and
move to the beat so they can see the
beat rather than they can hear the beat
yeah I would like ring ring ring you
here boom boom I'm like like it's
getting higher you feel me you feel me
like yes that's what I do yes I mean so
did you practice ahead of time were you
able to practice ahead of time yes I did
with this that Liz with the track I
practiced for a week and with rehearse
with uh everybody the whole show we ran
through it again and again all week so
no did you ever meet Rihanna did you
ever meet her and talk with her I did
not I did not get a chance to meet her
but she did DM me she did
can you tell us what she said she said
she was like black queen yes you're
amazing we BFFs in my head you were oh
you were amazing I would glad we killed
it so she said yeah but it was beautiful
but I knew everybody was so busy we
didn't get a chance to like meet but we
practicing the same vicinity and I was
like she did not look pregnant oh my God
weren't you a surprise too you were
surprised yes I found out after way
after because we were doing everything
so how do you decide the interpretations
you're going to give because it's almost
like you're giving a performance
yourself is that what you're trying to
do trying to provide and entertain I'm
really like trying to show her art
like really show her art how like show
it through
how I feel but through her songs how the
artist is herself like she's very she's
a visual performer yes so like I try to
be yeah right I gotta be as busy as
possible so so what was your thinking
going into the performance because it
seems like this is such a huge
opportunity so many people who didn't
know about about you and didn't know
about your skill this is a huge
opportunity isn't it for the deaf
Community yes
500 that was my thinking before like
getting there I was like I just hope I
pop off on a big scale like I hope I
reached a big scale for the deaf
Community like that's what I do and how
I got in my zone I'm quiet I'm crying
you were not quiet Justina
[Laughter]
student but what's your dream job do you
have a dream job
it would be like a performer like I I
grew up I really really really love
dance I dance 25 a like my mom was
dancing my whole family dances yes so I
really wanted to be a dancer performer
but with nursing like I my goal was to
really pave the way for deaf people to
become nurses and like help deaf people
like when they go into a hospital or
whatever they need that access right
there like they need well well Justina
told me before we went on stage before
we came on set she said I had the
attitude of go big or go home you went
big I sure did congratulations
congratulations cheering you on you made
us all so proud all so proud Justina
miles and Alberto we thank you too nice
to meet you too